for thousands upon thousands of people
this is certainly the most important
airport in the world right now
with the taliban advances and all routes
to the capital under their control hamid
karzai airport is the only way to get
supplies in
more importantly it's the only way out
the american embassy that dominates the
center of town will move its operations
to the airport joining us and british
military british embassy staff will
follow suit
short of a rethink it is the end game
impressive looking afghan army convoys
still crisscross kabul but recent events
suggest it's a veneer the military has
capitulated
thousands of embassy staff ngos and
foreign nationals will start their
journeys out from the green zone and the
fortified mansions that have been home
for two decades
passing kabul residents who have no
choice but to stay they'll all travel on
the airport road
guarded by british and american soldiers
to the gates
finally inside they'll be processed and
prepared for departure behind the high
blast walls and gun turrets of the
airport complex
planning for the exit is underway it
needs to be the taliban are closing in
so taliban have now taken logar
province's borders are only about 37
miles down the road behind me and it
feels inevitable now that kabul will
fall
the city is very much divided between
those who can leave or at least hope
they can leave and those who know they
can't
means this place is very tense now
crowding around computers manned by
experts groups of men are struggling to
fill out the application forms for
afghans who have worked for the
international community
security guards translators and a whole
array of jobs
the taliban will kill them
these visas are their only passage to
safety
but the process has been slow and time
is running out
ali worked as a us special forces
translator from 2011. he still hasn't
got permission to travel he's
representative of so many who are so
desperate
we serve for the american forces we
serve for the u.s and isil forces for
the collection forces they have to take
care about us
it is our turn to be helped
we help them you know we save their
lives
we were the people who communicate with
two cultures we are otherwise without
interpreters they did nothing
so now you're abandoned and scared yes
the vast majority of ordinary afghans
are slowly but surely preparing
themselves for the retaking of their
city by the taliban
on high ground in kabul the famous kite
runners know all too well their fun will
likely be stopped by the taliban
as that day nears the skies reverberate
to the sounds of helicopters
war machines of a war that seems lost
mr ramsey sky news kabul